there's no pizza for me cuz I'm going to
talk about Oshkosh
so what is it it's end of July every
year and a big physically big but
otherwise not very busy Airport in
Wisconsin and about 10,000 airplanes
come in people camp out people hang out
usually at least a hundred thousand
people a day there's a Boeing there's a
c-17 cargo plane a lot of experimentals
it's founded by the Experimental
Aircraft Association so there's a lot of
people who are passionate about home
building there you can see all the
airplanes parked
yeah there's 12,000 camping sites 40,000
campers there's 1,500 workshops and
seminars that you can take to learn or
you can just walk around and talk to
people and hang out so I planned this
trip for me and my friend ray he's a
helicopter pilot from Ireland and the
idea was to fly to Niagara Falls and
show him Niagara Falls and on the way
back up to Mackinac Island they saw
automobiles about 120 years ago and they
said this is a terrible technology
that'll ruin everything
they banned cars the only powered air
the only powered vehicle you can legally
have on Mackinac Island is an aircraft
they do have an airport anyway in the
back and we were gonna go to Toronto as
well so we had to get all this stuff
ready for international flying I had it
all carefully planned out where we're
gonna have 540 pounds of stuff which is
right at the payload of the airplane
with full fuel but then Alex Anna who
was just here she's an aerobatic pilot
at East Coast Aero clubs she said she
wanted to come too so then we had we had
to add a fuel stop there's all our merry
band of three people there's a whole
bunch of camping gear in the back that
you can't quite see option Cox becomes
temporarily the business busiest airport
in the world and you might say well how
can that be O'Hare has more flights but
their only option has only open about 10
hours a day because they close the
airport at night and they close it also
for a few hours
every afternoon for an airshow this is
somebody's iPad
I think screen capture of airplanes
flying in and around Oshkosh and these
are only the ones with the newest ad s
be out transponders so it doesn't show
probably this is probably only 20
percent of the total airplanes you have
special arrival rules if you're not a
[ __ ] then you have to fly and visually
circle around until it's your turn and
then they'll tell you you can't use the
whole runway you have to land on one of
these dots they'll say land on the green
dot if you are a [ __ ] you file IFR get
your IFR reservation when this daus
grade computer system confirm it with
this daus grade computer system that
nobody else wants to deal with and then
you get the whole runway and you just
land all right here's a picture of the
multifunction display and no actually I
guess this was some flat fried up
FlightAware later this shows that we
diverted a bit from Bedford we ended up
going up to Watertown New York so we
didn't we could have legally where
instrument-rated and everything we could
have flown through this you know these
rain showers but it's always smarter
just to go around if you can okay so we
flew over Niagara Falls we landed we had
that whole runway to ourself about
10,000 foot runway and it's actually
oriented east-west so we actually just
essentially we could have done the same
heading basically from Hanscom field all
the way to the end of the runway and
where we turned off you get there and
there's just on a thirty p-51 Mustangs
right next to your tent there are people
building this one-week Wonder an RV kit
where you get to pull rivets Oksana's
actually here and she can tell you about
her experience helping to build that
airplane
there's your b-1 bomber I love the
antiques here's one from the late 20s a
Lincoln Age airplane that has been
recently restored and flying there's
that replica autogyro beautiful Cessna
172 mold piper Comanche there on the
right
there's not a whole lot of helicopter
action there's a little bit this is
what's called a safari helicopter kit
that's how you know that you have real
confidence in your mechanical abilities
if you build and then fly your own
helicopter Piper Cub this is a guy who
stuck a Pratt and Whitney I think it's a
Pratt pt6 engine into a Polish Wilgus
short field landing airplane he added
fuel tanks it's such a fuel log now that
they had to add extra fuel capacity in
the struts and flies all around the West
going camping with his family all right
and that's called a traveler there were
a bunch of these so these are airplanes
from the 20s people are just using them
for transportation throwing a friend in
the back maybe and a tent and that going
and camping out of Oshkosh so I think
that's pretty cool all right there are
only five of these Piaggio seaplanes P
31 thirty Six's that still exist out of
63 that were built from 1948 to 1961 I
saw two of them parked next to each
other Oshkosh that's what makes it a
unique experience here's some kind of
airplane doing a simulated bombing run
meanwhile a family is there and their
personal dc-3 camping out here's our
little plane and the $99 tent from
Costco it seemed like a great idea
at the time I think we have a slide on
that okay this kind of summarizes 8:00
this is the unfortunate state of general
aviation now so we have the innovation
showcase and right in front of it a
piper Seminole which I think was
certified in the 1970s and certainly a
derivative of things going back a lot
harder than that
there were some interesting talks there
some heavy-hitters this guy Pat Anderson
is a professor at embry-riddle and he
said actually that we haven't really
seen anything in the electric aircraft
world because in the early days of Jets
they just took these piston airframes
and stuck a jet engine in them and they
didn't perform that differently from the
piston fighters but then you know five
years later they had the swept wings and
we would recognize as the modern fighter
jet so it completely was it was the jet
engine did completely transform the
aircraft but not immediately so he said
you know you're seeing some of this now
our people take a little two-seat
trainer and they remove the piston
engine and put in a electric motor with
the propeller but that's not really what
what we're really going to see is are
things that are much more like drones
there's an uber there was a guy from
uber that was very interesting
uber has aeronautical engineers working
for them designing aircraft and then
releasing the designs for free hoping
that well people will make them they're
claiming that they're gonna I don't know
they gotta I gotta pay somebody off in
the government to make this happen 2023
they say they're gonna be operating in
Los Angeles their idea is that you know
the world is going to be so congested
that people will pay up happily to hop
over the congestion and in relatively
short hops so ubers putting a lot of
money into this they have some partners
like Airbus pipistrelle the Slovenian
company we'll see what happens so some
round-the-world pilots were there
actually I don't know how many you guys
know this but Matt Guf Miller who was an
MIT between freshman and sophomore years
became the youngest person ever to fly
around the world in a Beechcraft Bonanza
I mean he was he was in there bonanza
and he he was the youngest person to fly
around the world but there's also at
Oshkosh we met this guy dick Rutan who
flew around the world
non-stop unrefueled in a clean design by
his brother Burt Rutan what else is Burt
Rutan famous for besides designing
aircraft does anybody know
what spacecraft that's true but yeah
spacecraft and aircraft but what else
canard plane so there are airplanes
climate change denial look it up he's
got like a hundred page book about the
scientific fraud of climate change but
anyway dick Rutan the other interesting
thing is before this nine-day flight he
was engaged to be married to Jeana
Jaeger and supposedly I what I heard was
it at Oshkosh was they have not spoken
since they landed in 1986
so in nine days there can be quite a
change in a relationship apparently we
met this this pilot shyest hawaii's I
don't know if that's the correct
pronunciation she grew up in California
and learned to fly relatively recently
and she also flew a bonanza all the way
around the world over 145 days so that
was interesting she actually said it
gets a little bit easier once you're out
over the ocean from a weather point of
view she said except for the
Intertropical Convergence of the equator
most weather is kind of a phenomenon of
being overland to me the most impressive
round-the-world pilot though was
actually an Italian guy that I met he
was in a Cirrus sr22 and he just flies
to Oshkosh every year he just loads up
in Italy turns the key and goes every
year flies over the Atlantic and then
flies back to Italy when it's over so I
thought you know that is actually the
coolest thing when it's not you know
even an adventure you're not gonna write
about it you're not gonna build a
webpage you're not gonna say you're you
know changing the world or helping to
achieve something you're not gonna set a
record you're just using your airplane
for transportation you want to get to
Oshkosh you have an airplane so why
should the fact that you're on a
different continent stopped you from
doing it you know a lot of people have
stopped doing home projects home repairs
so Oshkosh they actually have people to
teach kids you know how to hammer how to
drill how to cut sheet metal there's a
lot of great workshops there for kids we
were over by the Pioneer Airport and the
museum
here's the museum they have a replica
right flyer
the whole area devoted to the route and
designs I don't know how many I don't
know how many you know the MIT spin-off
Terrafugia I guess I think it was 12 at
least 12 years ago they said they were
gonna build a flying car so I took a
picture of this 1949 Taylor Aero car
which is actually a certificated flying
car and unfairly associated with
Terrafugia okay so this guy is kind of
an inspiration I think Paul po Perez nee
the founder of the Experimental Aircraft
Association he flew the most expensive
and highest performance aircraft of the
day he flew the p-51 Mustang the p-38
lightning and then he came home and said
well what's cool to do after flying you
know a 12,000 pound plus p-51 Mustang
why not just you know go to the basement
get some plywood nail it together and
build a really crummy plywood airplane
and that's what he did so it just shows
the joy you know you don't have to have
a high-performance state-of-the-art
airplane if you build it yourself or
you're goofing around you can have fun
and he did and he was a better pilot you
know then an alibi B I'm sure you know
in his p-51 so that that made me think
you know maybe we shouldn't be snobby
about these slim build airplanes because
if it was good enough you know po Perez
and you had fun with it all right so
here's some examples of homebuilts up at
the left there there's some kind of
canard velocity these folks spent 15
years building this helicopter and they
add about 40 hours of flight time on it
so it's you know to me you know in a
good in a good month at a flight school
a Robinson helicopter might fly 90 hours
or 100 hours in just a month so it was
taking them you know take them 15 years
plus to get to where a flight school
would get in a month but you know that's
kind of not the point it's not about
efficiency apparently that's a rotor way
kid I bet and they modified it by
sticking in a little tiny turbine engine
this is another modification this is a
Rutan design that became the bear coot
with a big piston engine this guy stuck
hey a turbojet engine here's the company
42,000 I think that doesn't include the
engine which is another 50 you can build
your own little single-seat jet Cirrus
was there serious actually has been kind
of a industry change in company it
didn't seem that way at the time because
it's very similar in performance the
Moonies and Piper's and Cessnas but they
really have revolutionized the way that
you know families buy airplanes now and
they've got over 7,000 of them the
parachute is I think critical to getting
modern people to accept this design and
also the glass cockpit does make life
easier although everybody else has
caught up there here's the icon a5 they
had the same booth every year a huge
amount of excitement people love it a
lot of people have ordered it they
haven't figured out how to build it you
know the price has gotten got to the
point where you can almost buy a Cessna
Caravan on floats with a jet engine for
the same price here's a retired airforce
and Southwest Airlines pilot with his
electric self launching pipistrelle
glider the past role is the company to
watch they do a lot of interesting stuff
in Slovenia
especially with electrics this is not
the kind of radar picture you want to
see when you're in the $99 tent I will
say I will say to Costco that it did
hold up remarkably well but it was scary
the seaplane base a few miles away from
Oshkosh they have the Oshkosh seaplane
base
I think it's on Lake Winnebago so you
take the shuttle bus or you drive over
there if you have a rental car so you'll
see you know they call it the quiet part
of Akasha it's quiet because you only
hear about three or four aircraft
engines running at any one time and
maybe two takeoffs or landings they have
four hangars vendors if you want to take
your dog and an unpressurized airplane
up to 18,000 feet you can buy this kit I
don't know what our golden retriever
would say about that
there's affinity groups
you know four different slices here's
one a woman who just like just for
female pilots of Muniz air shows every
day
my favorite acts actually were I did
like the game bird that was cool but I
also liked this first two were kind of
regular family airplanes just being
pushed to their limits it wouldn't be
legal just to go out and do that in a
barren because you can't do acrobatics
but he would help put it into
experimental category and then just fly
it right up to the G limits for which it
was designed and it's amazing to see
what these you know ordinary family or
business airplanes can do when pushed
there were one thing is interesting
about 150 Beechcraft aerobatic bonanzas
were built they were strengthened and it
is legal to do aerobatics in your four
seed Bonanza night airshow I guess
that's worth showing it is so unusual
they had explosives and fireworks
mounted on the aircraft so they fly
around at night shooting fireworks off I
guess you may have to you may have to
view that on your own which isn't so bad
a lot of warbirds everything from World
War two is still flying pretty much at
Oshkosh that Grumman tiger cat on the
right I'd never even heard of that
airplane until I saw it at Oshkosh
that's I think this is EA's own b-17
which they fly around and sell rides and
and stuff
oh and up on the top right is a flying
1/3 scale b-17 that some crazy guy spent
15 years building or more
that's EAA also they have a b-29 up
there the top right is my friend Erik
with his personal I guess he hasn't
found a ssin with a few other people but
he's essentially a personal dc-3 oh and
he's flying up to Europe this year for
the 50th anniversary of d-day is it the
50th no it can't be
what seventy-fifth sorry thank you I was
in math undergrad good illustration of
the value of a course 18 degree and
actually when I was in undergrad people
said how will you ever get a job if
you're a math major the engineers all
said that when you said well we can
become actuaries we can become actuaries
if there's a group of folks who are
passionate about warbirds down in the
south and they called their organization
the Confederate air Confederate Air
Force well they've had to change that
now they're the commemorative Air Force
and they're big into they brought the
Tuskeegee Airmen some of the remaining
p-51 guys from World War two there I
gave a talk with Noah that's Kate from
NOAA trying to get volunteer pilots to
fly sea turtles back from Cape Cod and
other northern places to Florida Sunday
morning it was time to leave I for me I
saw a 30% of what we'd hope to see and
1% of what there was to see as you can
see from the right that one week wonder
is coming together it actually did fly I
believe on Sunday so they they got it
built in seven or eight days we went to
Mackinac Island beautiful place up near
the Canadian border
everything is horse-drawn or bicycle fun
place to go in the airplane we went we
went and landed to Toronto City Island
Airport which is right in front of
downtown we had Chinese food
so the aquarium landed back in Bedford
so we burned up 15 hours of Hobbes time
split by three people that wouldn't be
too horrible it was about three thousand
dollars at retail next year I think it
might be time to go JetBlue so the
summary is that you know even as the
regulation has made light aircraft
almost as expensive to operate
commercially at least or for charter has
the big aircraft so but Oshkosh keeps
growing every year more people are
passionate about it so what you're
seeing in the aircraft world is like the
very high-end and the very low end or
kind of prospering
this is Oksana Stang she asked everybody
like what brings you to ash cops and
they always said the people I love
talking to the people here and I feel
that way too people go you know year
after year there's a whole bunch of
Link's here in the presentation and
finally you know what I like most about
it is and the reason I'm going back I
think is it's it's my safe space outside
of this room if I tell people you know I
have to go over to Hanscom field and buy
this little four seat airplane with a
piston engine they're horrified that's
just so dumb you could just drive to New
York in your Honda you could get a
ticket on JetBlue for no money like why
would you do that it's dumb but Oshkosh
is the one place where nobody will say
that
you